das hier sind die knusprigsten
Ofenkartoffeln deines Lebens und das
brauchen wir Kartoffeln Petersilie
Rosmarin Knoblauch Backpulver das ist
die Geheimzutat dadurch wird das Wasser
nämlich basisch die Oberfläche der
Kartoffeln wird beim vorkochen
vergrößert und sie werden knuspriger
schauen dann könnt ihr das Rezept ist
Kartoffeln hineingeben und 10 Minuten
vorkommen Olivenöl in die Pfanne und
Knoblauch dazugeben dann noch den
Rosmarin und das Öl aromatisieren das Öl
von Rosmarin und Knoblauch drin jetzt
werden wir die Kartoffeln so lange durch
bis eine kartoffelbreiartige Schicht auf
der Oberfläche entsteht
alles auf ein Backblech geben aber ganz
wichtig nicht überfüllen sonst wird es
nicht knusprig ab in den Ofen für 30
Minuten und bei der Hälfte einmal drehen
wir schauen jetzt mal wie sie aussehen
mama mia hört ihr das alleine schon
Knoblauch und Rosmarin wieder dran geben
Salz
ein bisschen frische Petersilie